POPULARITY AND PERHAPS PREVENT
ANGLE.
WITH THE ECONOMY UP, ISIS
PUMMELED, CRIMINALS DEPORTED,
12 APPELLATE JUDGES CONFIRMED.
REGULATIONS SLASHED AND
CONSUMER CONFIDENCE HIGH, ONE
WOULD THINK THE PRESIDENT'S
POLL NUMBERS WOULD BE ABOVE 50.
THEY'RE NOT.
WHO ERRONEOUSLY RELIED ON POLLS
>> TODAY WE HAVE A PRESIDENT
WITH SINKING APPROVAL RATINGS,
UNPOPULAR PIECE OF LEGISLATION,
THE TAX BILL SUPPORTED BY ONE
PARTY.
>> 24% APPROVAL RATING AMONG
WOMEN.
I'VE NEVER SEEN A NUMBER THAT
LOW.
>> THE PRESIDENT'S APPROVAL
POLLING.
>> THAT IS SOMETHING THAT IS A
RECORD LOW FOR EVERY PRESIDENT
DATING BACK TO EISENHOWER.
>> Laura: WELL, ALL THINGS
CONSIDERED, IT IS BETTER TO BE
A POPULAR PRESIDENT RATHER THAN
AN UNPOPULAR ONE.
REMEMBER WHEN BUSH'S POPULARITY
BEGAN TO TAKE A NOSE-DIVE IN
2005 BECAUSE OF THE IRAQ WAR?
AND HIS RESPONSE TO HURRICANE
KATRINA?
IT WAS BRUTAL.
BACK THEN W DISMISSED THE
REPORTS OF HIS LOW STANDING
WITH THE PUBLIC.
HE DIDN'T FRET MUCH OR DO MUCH
ABOUT IT.
THEN YOU REMEMBER THE DEMOCRATS
WENT ON TO WIN THE HOUSE, THE
THEN WHAT HAPPENED TWO YEARS
LATER WITH THE HE CON  --
ECONOMY IN TATTERS, BARACK
OBAMA WAS ELECTED.
NOW BACK TO TRUMP.
HE IS A STRONG POPULOUS CORE.
OF COURSE HE WANTS TO BE
POPULAR.
AND HE UNDERSTANDABLY GETS
FRUSTRATED WHEN HIS MESSAGE
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE BREAKING
MADE SOME MISSTEPS.
HE IS NOT PERFECT.
THE MEDIA POUNCED ON THEM.
THE BUNGLED TRAVEL BAN, FIRING
OF JIM COMEY AND THE DECISION
TO GET INVOLVED IN THE ALABAMA
SENATE RACE AT ALL.
THAT, OF COURSE, DEMOCRATS HAVE
HARPD ON THE PHONY RUSSIAN
EFFECT ON THE PUBLIC PSYCHE.
GILLESPIE IN VIRGINIA "THE NEW
THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO BE PUT OFF
BY HIS BRASHNESS, BLUNTNESS,
TWEET STORMS AND NOW SAY THE
CNN TRUMP BASHERS, HIS LACK OF
HUMAN EMOTION.
EXPRESSING CONDOLENCES.
HE DOESN'T DO THAT.
FIRST HE EXPLOITS IT FOR
POLITICAL PURPOSES.
>> THIS ADMINISTRATION IS
ENGAGED IN A LARGER GAME OF
TRYING TO CONTAIN THE
PRESIDENT'S WORST IMPULSES.
>> I HEAR PEOPLE SAY DIEHARD
TRUMP PEOPLE WE WANT HUMANITY.
>> NO POLITICIAN CAN WIN
WITHOUT EMPATHY.
HE WON WITH NUMBERS THAT
SUGGESTED PEOPLE SAYING WE
DON'T THINK HE UNDERSTANDS
PEOPLE LIKE US.
IS IT CATCHING UP WITH HIM NOW?
I THINK THE ANSWER IS YES.
>> YOU CAN'T LEARN EMPATHY.
>> Laura: WELL, I DISAGREE WITH
THESE CLOWNS AND HERE'S WHY.
MAYBE THE PRESIDENT IS SHARING
HIS EMPATHY IN A DIFFERENT WAY.
I WOULD ARGUE IN HIS FIRST YEAR
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS SHOWN
EMPATHY FOR THE PEOPLE OF THIS
COUNTRY IN ACTION IF NOT IN
WORDS AT ALL TIMES.
THINK ABOUT HIS DEEP FEELING
FOR THE WORKING PEOPLE, THE
MIDDLE CLASS, AMERICANS OF
FAITH AND JOB CREATORS,
ENTREPRENEURS, IT'S ALL EVIDENT
IN HIS POLICIES.
SO IF RIDDING THE SUBURBS OF
SHOWING EMPATHY FOR THE MIDDLE
CLASS, THEN WHAT IT IS?
SPURRING JOB CREATION AND
DRIVING THE ECONOMY ISN'T
SHOWING EMPATHY FOR THE WORKER?
THEN WHAT IS IT?
I'LL SAY IT IS DRIVING BLACK
UNEMPLOYMENT TO AN ALL-TIME LOW
EMPATHY TO THE AFRICAN-AMERICAN
COMMUNITY?
THEN WHAT IS IT?
TO PRESIDENT TRUMP I SAY THE
FOLLOWING.
YOU'VE ACCOMPLISHED SO MUCH
THIS YEAR.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO GIVE YOU
CREDIT.
SIDE WITH MAYBE JUST A FEW
TWEAKS, A FEW MODEST CHANGES.
PERHAPS THE TIME HAS COME TO
PUT ASIDE A FEW OF THE TWITTER
BATTLES.
I LIKE THE TWEETS BUT NOT ALL
OF THEM.
NOW IT'S TIME TO HUMANIZE THE
AGENDA THAT YOU'VE BEEN
FIGHTING FOR.
YOU SEE, YOUR PREDECESSORS
BARACK OBAMA AND BILL CLINTON
WERE MASTERFUL, THEY COULD TURN
ON THE MACHINE, THEY COULD BEAR
HUG AT THE DROP OF A HAT.
WHILE THEY WERE OFTEN ALL
EMOTION, THEY WERE AT THE SAME
TIME OFTEN NO ACTION.
I WOULD SAY IT'S POSSIBLE TO DO
BOTH.
I WAS THINKING TODAY ABOUT THAT
INCREDIBLE EVENT THAT YOU HELD,
HAD LOST LOVED ONES AT THE
HANDS OF ILLEGAL ALIENS.
IT'S AN IMPORTANT REMINDER OF
HOW POLICY AND EMPATHY CAN
ALIGN.
AND WHEN YOU LISTEN AND TEACH,
NOBODY DOES IT BETTER.
AND IF THAT'S NOT EMPATHY, WHAT
STRUCK HOUSTON AND YOU VISITED
THE SHELTER HOUSING FLOOD
VICTIMS.
THAT WAS POWERFUL.
IF THAT'S NOT WHAT EMPATHY,
WHAT IS?
I LIKE SEEING YOU OUT AMONG THE
CHILDREN, THE ELDERLY, FACTORY
WORKERS, VOLUNTEERS.
YOU CAN BE REALLY CHARMING AND
SEE THAT.
MY RADIO LISTENERS TODAY
OFFERED THEIR ADVICE WHAT YOU
SHOULD DO BEFORE THE MID-TERMS.
ONE SUGGESTED A TWICE MONTHLY
AND INTRODUCE THEM TO THE
PEOPLE WHO WILL BE IMPACTED
GREAT POLITICS AS WELL.
AND I ALSO LIKE THE FACT THAT
YOU DELIVER YOUR MESSAGE
DIRECTLY IN THAT SCENARIO WITH
OR WITHOUT THE MEDIA'S COVERAGE
OF IT.
I WOULD SAY IT'S TIME TO GOVERN
ALL THE PEOPLE.
TO TAKE YOUR AGENDA TO THE
INNER CITY, TO SUBURBIA, TO THE
CHURCHES AND THE AREAS OF THE
COUNTRY THAT HAVE BEEN SOMEWHAT
OR REALLY UNRECEPTIVE TO THE
POPULOUS CONSERVATIVE MESSAGE.
IT IS HARD TO BE A NATIONAL
PARTY, ISN'T IT, WHEN EVERY
YORK RIGHT OFF THE BAT.
AND THERE IS NO REASON THE
DEMOCRATS SHOULD HAVE A
MONOPOLY ON THE COAST.
THAT'S ABSURD.
JUST YOUR PRESENCE, JUST
AND I SAY IF THAT ISN'T EMPATHY